two or three times a year
ubisoft cracks open my chest like a
walnut scoops out my heart
and slams it against the wall i am of
course talking about splinter cell or
should i say the lack
of splinter cell let's see if we can
figure out exactly what happened to our
grizzled operative
sam fisher alright maybe i'm being a
little dramatic but if you clicked on
this video you must feel at least a
fraction of my pain
since the last splinter cell game
ubisoft has developed six main line
assassins creed games if you include
valhalla three watchdogs games if you
include legion
two division games and five far cry
games if you include the sixth entry
which drops next year
technically ubisoft just announced a new
vr splinter cell game on the way but i
think my point still stands i'm talking
about a classic
aaa splinter cell experience right here
now before we get into why i think we
haven't seen a splinter cell game in
seven years we need to address the
elephant in the room
apart from splinter cell stealth action
redefined most of these games became
less profitable with each new entry at
least according to vg charts which
admittedly doesn't really have all the
information but as of november 2013
splinter cell blacklist sold just over
2 million copies underperforming the
company's expectations
now from a purely financial perspective
it's easy to see why the splinter cell
franchise has taken a back seat to the
division
far cry and assassin's creed all of
which are either more consistently
profitable franchises have long-term
earning potential
or are in genres that are widespread in
popularity but ubisoft knows how
valuable the splinter cell ip is or at
least how recognizable sam fisher is
and it certainly hears folks like you
and me asking for a new one on a regular
basis
it's why in recent years sam fisher has
made an appearance in almost every tom
clancy game
in an interview with ign ceo eve gamow
said
when you create a new entry you have to
make sure you will come with something
that will be different enough from what
you did before last time we did a
splinter cell we had lots of pressure
from all the fans saying
don't change it don't do this don't do
that so
some of the teams were more anxious to
work on the brand
now there are some things and some
people that are now looking at splinter
cell
taking care of the brand at one point
you will see something
but i can't say more than that so with
all that in mind it's safe to say that
ubisoft hasn't forgotten about splinter
cell
and sam i mean obviously they just
announced a new vr title put him in the
two most recent ghost recon games and
rainbow six siege
even though he's not voiced by michael
ironside isn't wearing night vision
goggles on his default skin is dressed
like they picked him up on the streets
and is calling himself zero
but he's there call me zero however
putting sam fisher in a game and making
a splinter cell game are two very
different endeavors
and ubisoft knows this too gemo even
said that you have to come up with
something that will be different enough
from what you did before
and he's right sort of the problem is
that ubisoft's most successful games
today
actively go against the design
principles of the original games
let's compare the best splinter cell
game with the most recent tom clancy
game ghost recon breakpoint
chaos theory is a linear level based
game breakpoint boasts an open world
in chaos theory you play as one defined
character breakpoint lets you create and
customize a character from scratch
chaos theory has very little player
progression as in you don't unlock perks
abilities or new weapons the more you
play
meanwhile breakpoint puts a huge
emphasis on progression with tiered loot
drops and a robust skill tree and class
system chaos theory had an excellent
co-op mode
but the meat of the experience was its
single player campaign
breakpoint was built around co-op
allowing friends to drop
in and out with repeatable missions now
let's zoom out a little and take a look
at ubisoft's most successful
aaa franchises assassin's creed odyssey
far cry 5 and watch dogs 2
are all open world games with skill
trees and some form of character
customization
sure assassin's creed and watch dogs
don't let you create your character but
you can still change their looks with
armor and clothes and of course you can
play both watch dogs 2 and far cry 2
cooperatively from start to finish
this familiarity between titles was
largely due to ubisoft's editorial team
which gave a handful of people a lot of
influence over ubisoft's games
so then the question is how do you do
all that in a splinter cell game
you can't get rid of sam because sam is
at the center of the series so that
rules out player creation
you could let players customize sam's
uniform but you can only go so far with
that
sam is a professional with years of
experience under his belt
i can't imagine he'd wanted to play with
anything other than a black or camo
jumpsuit you also can't really give sam
an unlockable skill tree for the same
reason
sam is a professional and he shouldn't
be unlocking faster takedowns or
whatever
multiple decades into his military
career however you could get around this
with unlockable gear and weapons
co-op on the other hand is an
interesting one because chaos theory
conviction
and blacklist had excellent co-op
missions but those games were designed
first and foremost the single player in
mind apart from blacklist
co-op felt like its own separate entity
in fact most of what i just proposed was
part of splinter cell blacklist
there were light customization options
as you complete admissions you earn cash
that let you purchase new tech and
weapons and the co-op was
naturally interwoven with the single
player campaign the issue as you know by
now was that blacklist
underperformed and that michael ironside
didn't voice sam for [ __ ] sake who is
andre cobin
andre cobin pretended to kill my
daughter to give someone leverage over
me
so now let's go back to what eve said in
the interview you have to come up with
something that will be different enough
from what you did before
by all accounts i'd say blacklist did
this but when you look at the direction
ubisoft was heading at the time
splinter cell was a square peg being
jammed into a round hole
so if ubisoft's attempt to modernize
splinter cell failed then what does that
mean for the future of the series
well it means a lot of waiting like i
said earlier ubisoft
knows the value of the splinter cell ip
i find it really hard to believe that we
won't see another splinter cell game but
when you consider blacklist and
ubisoft's current portfolio it's hard to
see how a new splinter cell game could
fit in
however there's one thing i haven't
touched on yet we live in a
post metal gear solid world throughout
splinter cell's entire history it had
been competing with one of the most
well-known video game franchises of all
time
metal gear solid without the promise of
a new metal gear game on the horizon
there is a growing stealth action game
void in the market and of course
ubisoft knows this too yeah a few i've
heard they don't make them like me
anymore
there was this other guy though army
infiltration he wore
a bandana or something i heard he
finally retired
really yep it's only me
better yet metal gear solid 5 the
phantom pain proved that not only can
you make an
open world stealth game but you can make
a damn fine one
while i'd still prefer a more linear
experience i think there's a lot of
potential for an open world splinter
cell game if ubisoft builds off metal
gear solid 5's excellent foundation
maybe instead of two big maps like an
mgs5
there can be multiple smaller semi-open
world maps with a wide array of
objectives and a day night cycle to give
you and sam some tactical options
they could even have a similar r d
mechanic that lets you invest in
research new third echelon tech for sam
to use on the field the other more
important thing to consider is that
metal gear solid 5 was a big seller
selling over 6 million copies before the
end of 2015.
the biggest hurdle here would be finding
a way to tell a meaningful splinter cell
story with sam fisher at the center of
it
at this point i think a reboot would
make the most sense rhett cunning all
the events of previous games cause it
did get kinda messy near the end there
but you have to imagine that the same
day konami and kojima parted ways
ubisoft had a meeting about sam fisher
and the future of the splinter cell
series
but once again it's really hard to
imagine what a splinter cell game would
be like today with ubisoft's modern game
design principles in mind
and if i'm being honest i have a really
hard time picturing a new splinter cell
game staying true to its history under
these design philosophies
the last thing i want is an open world
live service splinter cell game with
micro transactions and a heavy emphasis
on multiplayer i know this is a rather
pessimistic take but if you look at
ubisoft's current lineup it's hard to
imagine that a new splinter cell
wouldn't follow suit
but there is a glimmer of hope after
breakpoint's disappointing launch eve
mentioned that one of the major
issues it faced was that it didn't stand
out in the industry amidst its own games
remember that ubisoft editorial team i
was talking about earlier while ubisoft
plans to rethink how that team
operates this restructuring was possibly
why so many of its games including
watchdog's legion got pushed
i can't think of anything that would
stand out more among ubisoft's tom
clancy portfolio than a somewhat linear
single player focused splinter cell game
especially with the new consoles on the
way imagine a next-gen splinter cell
game leveraging ray tracing tech and hey
if they can't part with micro
transactions and let's be honest here
they can't then let's save that for a
refresh spies vs mercenaries mode
but to take things back to eve's quote
one more time a big reason splinter cell
has been put on hold
is because of obnoxious fans like me who
have an unwavering idea of what a
splinter cell game should be
so i'll spare you and ubisoft my opinion
of what i think the next splinter cell
game should be
well actually hold up before i go let me
leave you and ubisoft if you're watching
with one last thing
you can't have sam fisher without
michael ironside
i can't believe i have to say this but
he just brings so much life to that
character
without him sam fisher is just a angry
disgruntled
old military man it just doesn't quite
work
but anyway with that thank you all so
much for watching and we'll see you next
[Music]
time
[Music]
you